in just days Dancing with the Stars will
have a new mirror ball champ and this is
one of the closest finales that I can
remember it's down to gma's ginger Zee
model nyle DiMarco and UFC fighter page
Van Sant the question is who's gonna win
this thing and I'm sure you all have
your favorites well I crash their final
rehearsals to get inside lock you made
it all the way the finals I mean this is
right like really it's do or die they're
all looking pretty amazing and rehearsal
but the nerves are starting to kick in
most stressful thing for me has been our
bodies are exhausted when we're done
with that dance I want to look at valve
and I want him to be beaming I want him
to be so proud and so happy the
competition is fierce all three pros
have one before and the team's average
scores for the season are really close
Monday's freestyle kicks off the 2-night
season finale we know niall and Peeta
will be bringing out the big guns their
song of choice the sound of silence
obviously I can't hear so I think we're
gonna bring that out for our freestyle
dance Paige is you know she does some
results and flips I think what's been
our charm is our charisma what is gonna
set your freestyle apart I think for me
what's really special is Mark really
picked this dance to format it around
meet somewhere over the rainbow just
like popped at me on the on the page and
I came in on the page and I came in the
next day and was just like thing we
should do this
when I did this did the show in season
five I wasn't allowed to do any lifts
because I didn't make the finals and I
was wondering if you can help me do a
lift with Val muscle glad you guys are
doing it it was just a little bit
heavier than i expected that's all but
if I ever make it on dancing again I
want him as my partner